I've been in business for 14 years. Last
year, our companies in total did over
$250 million in aggregate revenue. I
co-own the platform School, which is
over 22 million users. And school's a
platform that allows people to start and
scale digital businesses. And so, I have
access to quite literally millions of
data points on what makes digital
businesses work and what doesn't. And
so, in this video, I'm answering your
questions about how to scale.
>> I sell dreams and I built an ecosystem
to make it happen. Essentially, what
does that mean? Let's
>> get into it. I start off flipping homes.
>> Okay. Thank you. And then uh
>> okay I started off flipping homes and it
got to a point where
>> that's a hope and opportunity. Hey, it
works.
>> I flip houses. Got to a certain point.
We got about 30 40 consecutively every
year in the same market. Revenue is
about 4 mil.
>> Okay.
>> Adjusting out line itself. It got to a
point there's too much competition. You
had a hard time being profitable per
flip.
>> So then develop a model where we convert
competition to collaboration. Start a
contracting company instead of buying
the product becoming the product. and
then starting a coaching channel where I
feed this ecosystem vertically
integrated HVAC company, roofing
company, uh dumpster company,
contracting, the whole nine yards. So,
teaching people how to do it and I'm
giving them the process how to do it.
All that is different revenue drips for
me. Uh what's stopping me? I got too
busy too fast and uh owner operator for
a long time up until about 3 months ago.
Hired a COO now transitioning a lot of
the operations stuff onto her. really I
don't know what the [__] I'm doing
because like I'm trying to transition
myself out. I don't know how to run a
COO.
>> Why are you trying to transition out of
the role or out of the company?
>> A little bit of both. So out of the role
because
>> to be honest, I don't really care about
the revenue uh growth factor. I care
more about the impact. So
>> a promise I made myself is I want to
impact at least five like uh 1 million
lives before I die. So how do I do that?
I'm not going to be doing that flipping
homes at a small scale. But I built a
company that's so based in locality that
I'm trapped within it because it's so
local. My team is there, my resources,
my companies. The coaching program only
makes sense because it's local. But
because my market size, there's only so
many people I can get consecutively
every time unless I keep dropping
prices. The opposite of increasing
price.
>> So what does that mean? I have to go to
a national stage is how to how do I take
this coaching at a massive scale? And
that's where I'm stuck at because I'm
too busy in the operations. And that's
where Amy came in as a COO to kind of
help me get out of it and focus on the
next phase of, you know, the origin
story.
>> So, dude, like I I I appreciate the
national scale vision. I think you could
probably get to given the ticket size
and how you can monetize the customer in
all these hundreds of ways. Like the the
reason you would do that setup is so
that you could dominate a local market.
You're not dominating a local market
right now. You're barely getting
started. And so you could probably
realistically get between Fagville um
and Raleigh, you could probably get to
100 million a year
>> just in that market alone.
>> Yeah. And I think if you just take your
eyes off of like I want to conquer the
entire world. It's like maybe. But like
in order to conquer the world, you have
to conquer a country first, right? And
before you conquer a country, you got to
conquer a city. And right now, you
haven't conquered a city. And so what
happens is when armies overexpand, they
collapse. And so you need to fortify
your base better because 10 dude 10 a 10
a month is nothing.
>> So what do you recommend? Do I try to
automate what I have
>> or do I just put myself more into it and
double?
>> Yeah. I think you should just ignore the
national thing.
>> Yeah.
>> And let me just ask the simple question.
Can you could you sell 20 people a week
right now? Not like let me say it
differently. Can you handle 20 people a
week?
>> We will be soon. Now that the co has
kind of taken. You could have an 8x
increase in sales within your current
infrastructure. So that would take you
from 4 to 32.
>> That solves a revenue problem, not the
impact problem.
>> Do you make content?
>> I don't have time. Hence squad, if you
couldn't tell. Yeah,
>> but that's where I'm slacking the most.
>> Yeah, it's the content. Um, it would be
far easier for you to just make content
about the stuff you're doing and impact
millions of people that way.
>> Yeah.
>> Than
every single person in America to be a
home flipper.
>> And that's not achievable anyway.
>> I agree.
>> It's more about the financial education
like selling the the dream of like you
can be something more than just what you
think you are and where you came from.
>> And you can make content about that and
you can distribute it for free with
leverage. It's a beautiful thing. And so
like you can be legit because you have a
legitimate business and then you can
talk about it and help all these other
people and then you just keep growing
this thing.
>> Okay. So double down locally.
>> Yeah. You already have all the like you
went through whatever the hell you did
to go through and build all that stuff.
It's like you just built it and you're
like, you know what, I'm going to leave
it now and I'm going to do another
thing. It's like no. Like I'm glad you
brought the COO in, but it's probably so
that she can do some of the stuff you're
doing now so you can do the stuff you
know you should be doing but you're not.
And so like you want to do the impact,
you see you don't have time. You have
the COO go make some content. It's not
going to take that long anyways. And
that way you can scratch your impact
itch. And then for everything else, it's
like you need to learn how to run paid
ads and sell [__] cuz like you for sure
can sell 20, 50, 100 people a week in a
local market, no problem for the offer
that you have.
>> Should I increase pricing to make it
better or should I keep it where it's at
given that it does feed my other
channels?
>> You probably have a better time just
like charging 100 grand and saying
you'll do that stuff for free or at
cost.
Yeah.
Um, but yeah, I mean, can you raise
prices? It's just like, can you sell and
can you like Yes, you could. Typically,
an offer like this is 100 grand.
>> Yeah.
>> So, usually they have a done with you
style offer that's between 15 and 25 and
then there's a uh total turnkey offer
which is $100,000.
>> No one in my market can afford that.
That's the problem.
>> That is just not true.
If I I'll no one in your market that has
heard of you through word of mouth of
you emanating your presence into the the
the workshops that you run once a
quarter or whatever have can afford it
if you run ads. Yes. It's just that like
how many people show up to your thing?
>> The venue holds 55 is packed out every
time.
>> Yeah. 50. So you have 55 people a month
that come in the doors
>> every three months. Yeah.
>> Every three months. Right, dude. So it's
like the way this looks in reality is
you'll bring a 100 people in the room
and you'll do three of those in a day
and you'll pitch and you'll close 10 15
you'll close three or five at the you
know like the 100k and you'll close a
handful at the you know call it 15 to
25k and that's that's the business. So
you like you're you're like you see 200
people a year and you're like my market
can't afford it. It's like well those
200 can't. It's like look at 2,000. I'm
sure there are some. Let me give you a
stat. 9% of people in America have a
million dollars in terms of their net
worth. So if you include the ass like
buy their home, like 9%. It's
significantly higher than you think it
is. They just look older.
>> Real. Okay. We sell motocross training.
>> Okay.
>> So we we hold 5day camps. What we did to
be able to get our projection to 26 to
the 4 million is we scaled down our
single day tour dates. We were we we did
more in 24. We went all the way to we
scaled from 70 single day tour dates in
23 to 140 of them in 2024 and it was
just a ton of operational drag. I mean
it was like we were like a rock.
>> It was nuts.
>> But what we realized and looking back on
it is the bottom 20 of those were net
negative. The the next 20 were net less
than $1,000. So inconsequential. And
then I started looking at in 2024 we did
three of the 5day camps kind of as a
test run. Each of those net well over
100 grand each and I'm like well hang on
a second. This is the answer. So this
year I told the team at first I called
them. I said hey I just had an epiphany.
Here it is. We're going to do 10 camps.
And I said actually no we're actually
going to do 25. And they're like 25?
What do you mean 25? Yeah.
>> My question is,
>> do I continue to my
>> Were you just able to charge more for
the 3-day than the one day?
>> Uh, the Earth, sorry.
>> So, the one day is $300, which is
probably not enough. The fiveday is
$1,200, which is definitely not enough.
>> Uh, so that's what part of the question,
too.
>> Cool.
>> Um, I want to continue to scale the five
days and scale down the single days, but
my fear is we basically own the space.
Nobody else does what I do. It's pretty
large market.
Um, there is one copycat company and
he's trying to hit all these single day
tour dates in the regions that we're
doing them. So, I'm afraid if I scale
them down too much,
>> we won't copy the model that makes the
money.
>> That's a great point. Yeah.
>> Love this for us, right?
>> I hope he does.
>> Okay. I could honestly I could go home
right now and I'd be happy after that.
>> Yeah, you're right. You're right. And I
feel more confident that I don't think
he could do what we could do anyways,
but he certainly can't do what we can do
in a five-day event. I mean, we we've
run those five days like nobody else.
So,
>> yeah. And I'll land the plan on that for
you, too, which is that
>> you will never go out of business
focusing on the customer. And I I'll
tell you a quick story. So, the biggest
business mistake that I I've made, the
two most costly business mistakes I've
made, um, one of them has nothing to do
with this. This is the other one, which
has everything to do with this. Um, I
had a competitor that ended up taking a
bunch of my top testimonials that were
that we kind of converted to semi-mp
employees because they were big
evangelists back in the gym launch days.
And as soon as they took them and they
were they were big ads for me, all of a
sudden they were running ads for this
other guy. So, it's kind of like when
the Verizon guy went to the AT&T,
remember that that that switch over that
actor? It was kind of like that. And
this guy was offering one-on-one
coaching um to help people out. I never
did that. And so and they were cheaper.
So they were cheaper. They were doing
one-on-one and they had some of my top,
you know, customers uh becoming
advocates. And they said that the 10 of
them had come they partnered. He
partnered with these 10 people or
something like that. And when that
happened, I got r my feathers got all
ruffled. And I was like, it's war time.
We got to, you know, we got to go to the
mattresses. We got to really, you know,
change change the business up. And so I
did this big kind of like relaunch
internally to my existing customer base.
And um I said, "We're," you know, I did
this big value stack and I said, "You're
going to get all this extra stuff, not
for the same price you're paying me, but
for less." And so I took my existing
recurring base and I reduced my revenue
by $500,000 topline per month. And so
that translated because we take it off
topline and and the cost went up. So I
increased my costs and I took my topline
down by 6 million. And I ended up losing
in profit somewhere in the neighborhood
of $6 to $7 million a year for that
business at the time. I then ended up
selling that business obviously and the
business never recovered that profit. It
stayed there. And when I did make that
move, the first comment in the chat
after I dropped that it was less was a
complaint that I had not done it
earlier. So it was not, "Thank you so
much for lowering the price and giving
us more shit." It was, "I can't believe
I was paying more.
And I was like, I want to [__] kill
myself.
And and here was the best part of all.
My churn changed zero. So I just cut my
top line by 20%. Churn remained the same
because the willingness to pay change
that I made. I basically reduced it from
call it 3,000 a month to $2,500 a month.
It actually made no real difference in
whether someone would cancel or not. It
was past a threshold that this is a lot
of money. And so it changed nothing. I
just made less money. And then when I
sold the company, that six got
multiplied by a lot. And so that
probably cost me in the neighborhood of
probably $50 mill million. And so the
big lesson that I learned there was that
I shouldn't and that that competitor
ended up killing that business because
it wasn't [__] profitable. And so I I
was the market leader and someone came
in to undercut me and then I said, "Oh,
I'll copy the moron."
>> It's easy to let happen.
>> Yes.
>> And so don't lose $50 million. Let him
let him figure that out for himself. You
just focus on the customer and you'll
win.
>> Good answer. Thank you.
>> Appreciate you.
>> If you're a business owner, I'd like to
invite you out to come to our
headquarters in Vegas to see how we
scale businesses using what we call the
value acceleration method, which is a
compilation of all the stuff that we've
learned, breaking down different
businesses across different industries.
And if that sounds at all interesting,
you can click below and book a call and
we'd love to potentially meet you and
see you in person.
>> I sell coaching to real estate agents.
>> Mhm. Um, I do two and a half million.
Um, I'd like to double it. What's
stopping me? That's a good question.
Your boy Ed, he seems to think I could
be just super famous.
>> And he's like, you need a brand manager.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, you know, he's like, you need
somebody that has already kind of
achieved that with someone else, right?
So, I guess my question is, how do I
find that person? Cuz 99% of the stuff
out there is scams basically.
>> Totally. And I would even define them as
scams. I just people that are not that
competent. scam.
I think it comes down to deception. Um
whether they intend to deceive or they
just aren't that good. Um but back back
to your point, I yeah, I I agree. So
fundamentally, if you want to just make
more money and you are a brand that
promotes itself, then you need to
advertise more. Are you constrained on
your delivery?
>> Delivery as far as the fulfillment?
>> Yeah.
>> No, it's group coaching. It's easy.
>> So you could double the amount of
customers you have right now and it
would be
>> quadruple. Yeah.
>> Okay. Well, then yeah. I mean, this is a
pure advertising play. Yeah,
>> you probably I mean
>> I'm I'm interviewing sales guys and I'm
looking at paid ads like hiring people
for that. So like I'm getting into that.
>> Yeah, the paid side is going to give you
call it like a one time 3 to 5x off of a
baseline. Uh not a promise or guarantee,
just saying like that's that's what I
would say is kind of typical if you've
gotten to this point off of just
organic. Um, obviously we can help you
with that stuff, but like uh the
long-term kind of like uh well that you
need to keep digging is you want to
so think of it like this. So you have
just imagine this is your audience right
now. You're monetizing these people,
right? The people who are just like
super hot. They love you forever and you
continue to promote and you know this
gets filled up with new eyeballs and
then they come up because they see your
stuff and then they give you money. Yay.
Right? So if you if you uh when you
start doing if you do more organic and
do it across more platforms, do it more
consistently, do it with higher volume,
do with higher quality, then what you're
going to do is you're going to grow this
this base. This percentage will stay
about the same, but now it's going to go
to here, right? So then that dollar sign
goes up. That's a great long-term play.
And you just want to keep growing the
pyramid.
>> What ads will do is that ads will keep
this the same and then it'll move this
line down. And so you want to do both.
Mhm.
>> So, like in the short term, if I was
like, how do I tr like double your
business? It's like that wouldn't be
that difficult. I would just be like,
cool, just pull the ad lever. It's done.
>> But if we were looking at a 10ear
horizon, then I would say, well, we need
to do both of these in parallel. We need
to continue to plant the seeds and then
the ads kind of reach off the top and
and skim. Does
>> that make sense?
>> Yeah, for sure. So, how do you find an
ad manager? I mean I mean I mean I mean
a brand manager.
>> So, that that's good.
>> Yeah. The best thing I mean I just we
just poach. We just I mean just
outreach. Hey, you've crushed it with so
and so. Can I pay you more to do it
here?
>> Right. And so I guess how do you realize
who those people are to poach? Like who
>> look at the brands that you admire and
then reach out to them and offer them
more money to do it for you.
>> But you see the brand but you don't
really know who's behind the brand.
>> LinkedIn like Frank and like
>> Yeah.
>> solvable. Gotcha.
>> For sure. Solvable. Yeah. I mean, and
most of the people who are really good
at media stuff do have some presence
anyways on their own, so they don't make
themselves invisible. Um, like you could
probably chat GPT search who are the
people who are involved with that.
>> Here's my question. Like like is that
something that could be outsourced?
>> You mean recruiting?
>> No, no, no, no, no. Not the recruiting
part like the like the brand manager
part.
>> No, I wouldn't recommend it.
>> Yeah. Bring somebody in house.
>> It's thing is what are the so what are
the core things to the business? So for
every business you have attraction,
you've got conversion, you've got
delivery, right? Those are the things
that are core to every business. IT,
recruiting, finance. I see all of these
functions as ancillary that aren't core
to value creation for the customer.
They're things that must occur for the
business to continue to be a business,
but not things that are core for the
value to be created. And so for you,
your brand is arguably the most
important asset that you have and for
sure would not be something that I would
outsource.
>> So bring somebody in house working
directly for me.
>> Yeah, I would poach somebody. Um,
obviously we've done we've hired a lot
of media people. We can help you with
that. Um, but beyond that, uh, I would
probably, if I'm doing order of ops,
it'll probably be, uh, because the thing
is is right now, are you selling, you're
selling, who's doing the sales?
>> Well, so I do it in a challenge.
>> That's the only time I offer it, you
know,
>> you do one to many, five day thing,
something like that. Okay.
>> And so I'm going to switch to book a
call, single cell guy, close
>> and do it on a recurring kind of
evergreen basis or still do it in this
long?
>> I'll do it both. I'll do both.
>> Yeah. Um but okay, but you're selling
straight to checkout.
>> Mhm. Got it. Um yeah, that motion um as
soon as you turn on ads is going to
break uh in all likelihood because it's
totally different selling to cold than
is to to warm. And so the
>> mean break,
>> you will not convert the same percentage
you currently do.
>> Yeah. No doubt. No doubt. No doubt.
>> By a lot. Um and so the whole the whole
the economics of the entire funnel will
change and so that'll take some
adjustment in motion. So just more like
preparing you for that because that's
what comes next.
>> Yeah.
>> So high level recruiting for brand
manager that's going to start building
the base. And then ads plus sales motion
are going to have to come in tandem
because they both have to be good. The
ads have to be good and the sales motion
has to be good. If the ads are great and
the sales motion sucks, it won't work.
If the sales motion is great and the ads
suck, it won't work.
>> Cool.
>> That makes sense for next steps.
>> What's up?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Go to LinkedIn and poach
somebody. Got it.
We sell sales coaching and lead genen to
financial adviserss. We're at 6.6
million. We'd like to be at 20 plus.
>> Um,
>> appound, paid ads, events. How do you
sell
>> paid ads?
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> Straight to VSL to phone team.
>> Correct.
>> Cool. Correct.
>> Yeah. Biggest thing is churn as with
pretty much all agencies.
>> Um, so we've basically transitioned from
lead genen company to sales coaching
company because we know that, you know,
advisors can't close. No offense to any
advisers in here, but um yeah, so we're
we're doing a lot of sales coaching now.
So we have like the big head longtail
where we can sell the lead genen on the
back end.
>> Okay.
>> So yeah, the main question is have you
seen other agencies successfully pivot
from lead genen to sales coaching or you
know in like very non-sales
uh or industries where founders or
business owners are sales deficient?
Have you seen companies successfully
train their clients on sales?
>> Yeah, sure.
>> So, like a gym launch, how did you guys
successfully do that across thousands of
gyms? We had something called boiler
room. We trained their trainers and
front desk people every morning and
drilled them, role played, and separate
them in the groups the same way we would
our own team. So, we just did it every
morning for them. And it was just an
add-on,
>> just group group roleplay basically.
>> Mhm. just like you'd have a sales
manager meeting where you'd role play
whatever particular part of the script
they were all struggling with. And so we
break we break sales training from the
team side, not on the one-on-one side,
into five parts. We've got intro, we've
got disco, we've got offer, and then
we've got uh you know, objections and
looping. And then fifth day is basically
whatever is kind of the hot topic of
what's the thing that we think is going
to benefit the team the most. And so
that's kind of how we rotate through. We
have to keep each part of the script
crisp, otherwise they'll [__] up
something. And so that keeps the short,
you know, the the the sword sharp. Um,
and that's what we did, you know, across
the team. We still we do that for our
teams, too. Um, but I think it's likely
that it's under basically you need to
provide more value or you need to lower
the price. And so, if you want to tackle
churn, it has to be like there are for
sure businesses that work in the space
that you're at. I think big head
longtail is a great model like charge
the upfront and then just make the
continuity much much smaller. So, it's a
no-brainer. Like they'll almost pay that
just to be kind of in the network. Sure.
>> And so this is I'll just I should have
said this earlier, but it's like I try
to answer the question so that it
affects as many people as possible in
this room. But the problem with
information and kind of quote coaching
or education type businesses is that um
people try to make continuity out of the
front end value that you're providing
and then the value drops once you have
the skill. And so you have to separate
out the consumables from the one-time
things. the onetime things also have
significantly more value than the
consumables do. Now sometimes they don't
have the money to pay for the onetime
thing because they don't have the skill
the onetime thing would give them. Yeah.
>> Right. That's kind of the issue. So um
in order to separate it, it's like you
just have to think what are the things
that they get on an ongoing basis. And
if we only sold that, what would the
price point be? Likely significantly
lower. And if we got them that skill, it
would be significantly more. But once
they have the skill, assume they have
the skill on the ongoing basis.
>> Yeah.
>> What would they still pay for? Now you
have the lead genen thing.
really I mean the lead genen oh everyone
wants it when they learn how to sell
using our process they stay
>> so the biggest thing is just making sure
they actually
>> so it's so it's like it's activation as
well so like getting them to come in and
actually engage
>> because most advisers
>> is it all remote
>> it's all remote and they don't they also
don't like sales like the word sales
like
>> they like cringe inside when they hear
it so we literally like ban the word
sales like we we just say consulting we
don't call them sales calls We call them
consults.
>> So like you know like that but
>> um yeah I'm just curious. So it sounds
like you just have to get better at
training them.
>> Yeah.
>> So
>> okay.
>> Your issue though is that if someone
gets activated they stick for sure.
>> For sure.
>> Well then all of the all of the effort
we have is how do we get them activated
like better faster which is going to be
a function of two things. One is going
to be are there some avatars
>> that are better than others right?
Right? So, we only sell those avatars.
And we split that into three buckets.
You've got demographics. What do they
look like? Right? You've got the
quantifiables, which is like what are
the uh what size business do they have?
Whatever. Um and then you've got the
ethnic the um uh I said demographics and
there's quantifiables. There's a third
one. I can't remember. But those two
will at least get you on a head start um
in terms of segmenting the traffic. So,
you can be like this is who the avatar
is. These ones have a significantly
higher likelihood of converting. And
what will happen when you do that is
your CAC will go up, but then your stick
problem will get fixed. Okay? So like
for example, if I sold everybody who
identified as a fitness person, then gym
launch would never have been able to
exist because I would have had too many
shitty customers who are personal
trainers who've got 10 clients,
whatever, and they can never pay and it
doesn't matter what I do. And so for me
to deploy the resources required to
actually get them up to snuff, I have to
have somebody who at their onset can pay
more
>> so that I can actually help them.
>> Okay?
>> Because below a certain extent, it just
needs to be DIY, which is a different
business, not the business I wanted to
be in.
>> So there's probably some advisors that
are better
>> that you need to basically scan out and
say, "All these people were not going to
service because they have a low
likelihood of actually working." And
maybe you need to adjust price to only
accommodate those people and that newer
avatar that's better. So this isly an
avatar issue. And then obviously the ops
on the back end in terms of activation
is what do oh yeah that's the third
bucket the behaviors. So what do the
people who have the right demographics
and the right quantifiables what
behaviors did they do that caused them
to activate and stick and what did the
other people who look like them not do
and then that becomes the activation
process we reverse engineer.
>> Makes sense. Quick last question. How
did you how did you optimize for for
time to value your launch? And how can
we potentially do something similar?
Because for us deal cycles are
>> Yeah. We'd email their list. if they
make a sale in the first seven days.
>> Okay, so just reactivation. Okay, sweet.
Appreciate you.
>> If you're doing a million dollars or
more a year and you'd like to get to 10
million or $100 million, I can promise
you absolutely none of that. But what I
can do is create an environment where
you can actually talk to other business
owners and players within those
businesses that are doing those numbers.
And for me personally, the big
breakthroughs that I had in my business
was when I came in with an open mind and
was like, I don't know what I don't
know. And so you probably have one of
those like how do I get my content to
scale? How do I recruit these first
sales people? How do I recruit my 20th
or my sal my VP of sales or director of
sales? Every single level of this game
has more complexity than the last. And
so if that sounds at all interesting,
I'd love to invite you out to our
headquarters for two days to talk to me
and the team, director of sales,
director of marketing, director of
strategy, director of ops, director of
investment, all the people that who
actually run our portfolio
atacquisition.com. And as a bonus, all
the other business owners in the room
are doing a million dollars plus. And
yeah, so this is your invitation. So if
that sounds interesting, click book call
if it's a good fit.